foreign
with around 7 million inhabitants and
located in the shores of the Black Sea
in Southeastern Europe is one of these
countries that is always in the middle
of some drama or other and where you
never know where things might end up
next going wrong to give you an idea we
are talking about a country that in the
political arena is a Monumental chaos in
2023 they are going to hold their fifth
parliamentary elections in two years yep
that's why I said five parliamentary
elections in two years this leaves Italy
Japan and even Israel practically as
apprentices in their particular art of
political chaos naturally that's not the
only extent of the drama either it may
surprise you but Bulgaria also has a
serious case of brain fog when it comes
to balancing its relations with the west
and with Russia
[Music]
just prior to the Russian invasion of
Ukraine that began on the 24th of
February 2022. bulgarians on the streets
thought highly of Russian dictator
Vladimir Putin never mind that he had
already invaded Crimea in 2014 or that
he is a SAT trap accustomed to violating
the most Elementary human rights
specifically 70 of bulgarians had a
favorable opinion of Putin in 2021 and
45 viewed Russia as an important
strategic partner
[Music]
and of course this is curious where we
realized that Bulgaria is a country that
has been a member of the European Union
since 2007 and NATO since 2004. did you
catch that with the European Union and
NATO So in theory you could say that
Bulgaria is fully integrated in the
western Camp as opposed to being under
the Russian orbit of influence however
as you will see reality paints a much
more complex picture and precisely the
war in Ukraine and the actions of Sofia
of the Bulgarian government I mean are a
good opportunity to try and understand
this apparent contradiction so without
further Ado let's get cracking
[Applause]
[Music]
Bulgaria is not only according to
Brussels own reports the poorest and
most corrupt country in the entire
European Union but it also probably the
most pro-russian at street level in the
entire Union with Hungary not far behind
that is you could say depending on the
circumstances Sophia either swings more
towards Brussels or towards Moscow at
least that's how it's been until
recently that is why many analysts of
international politics consider this
country to be a kind of Achilles heel
for the European Union and to see it as
a trojan horse for NATO to continue
referencing the what mythology of
ancient Greece so the question we should
be wondering is how on Earth is this
possible aren't they supposed to have
helped rescue Ukraine how on Earth does
that fit in with this whole story well
we'll take a look at it but first what
we have to see is where this fondness
for Russia comes from
the fact that so many bulgarians have a
favorable view of Russia or at least
they did until the invasion of Ukraine
took place has some logical reasons and
perhaps one of the most important is
paradoxically a historical one you see
Bulgaria is a country with a certain
shared history with Russia you have to
go all the way back to the second half
of the 19th century when Russian Emperor
Alexander II was instrumental in
liberating the Bulgarian Nation from the
Ottoman Empire there is even an
equestrian Monument dedicated to him in
the heart of Sophia Bulgaria's capital
entitled The Monument to the Tsar
Liberator the point is that this later
allowed for the creation of an
independent Bulgarian State because of
that relations between Bulgaria and
Russia have not only been historically
good but for a long time a favorable
view was cultivated that went so far as
to paint Russia as a liberating country
in fact Sophia even wanted to join the
Soviet Union and although this did not
happen in the end in practice it
functioned as the 16th Soviet Socialist
Republic
and yes okay I know what many of you are
thinking Grant is this something that
happened in the 19th century really
important for defining international
relations in 2023 well the truth is that
in this case we can say yes in fact the
traditional Bulgarian view of Russia is
clearly reflected in domestic politics
to give you an idea of the 28 parties
and coalitions that ran in the October
2022 elections about 15 were openly
pro-kremlin and although the severe
political fragmentation in this country
means that most of these parties do not
reach the minimum representation
threshold of four percent of the vote
and we put them all together the result
is that approximately one in four or
five bulgarians vote for clearly
russophile options which understandably
has had an important influence on the
government's reaction to the Russian
invasion well at least as far as the
official reaction is concerned
[Music]
while Sophia is providing Ukraine with
humanitarian assistance Bulgaria is not
sending weapons we're too close to the
conflict to be able to do that petkov
said but what if we were to tell you
that that was what was thought until
relatively recently but that over time
it has been shown to be nothing more
than a kind of Lie to avoid stirring up
national politics what if it turned out
that the former Bulgarian prime minister
kyrill petkov said one thing and did
just the opposite even if it meant
hiding the truth from members of his own
coalition government that's why I said
this is exactly what happened at the
beginning of the invasion petkov played
a key role and rescuing Ukraine and that
is something that has recently come to
light thanks to an investigation
published by the German newspaper velt
the question is what exactly did
Bulgaria do at the beginning of the
invasion and what were the consequences
for the country and for the petkov
government itself well I can already
tell you that this whole story is super
interesting so let's find out
[Music]
the man who lied for Ukraine
the Russian invasion of Ukraine blew up
the more or less balanced relations
between Russia and Eastern European
countries as a result Bulgaria rather
pro-russian as a country suddenly found
itself at a Crossroads you see the truth
is Bulgaria has traditionally been very
dependent on Russia as a country
especially when it comes to energy
supplies no less than 95 of the 3
billion cubic meters of gas consumed by
the country each year was supplied by
Russia and practically the same was true
of oil at the beginning of the war 60 of
the crude oil consumed by the bulgarians
came from Russia and was refined in a
plant that Lukoil has in bluegrass axeti
located under Bulgarian Black Sea Coast
however despite this compromising
situation the political problems that
could cause him petkov did not stand
still and managed to make his country
the first in the European Union to
completely cut off Russian gas Imports
especially after gasprom cut off the
supply in April 2022 something that
however he has so far been unable to do
with oil Bulgaria exempt from Russia Oil
Embargo until end of 2024. but wait just
a moment because you important part of
this story is not what we already knew
but what we didn't know
[Music]
partly taking advantage of this
exemption the Bulgarian government or
rather petcov and his trusted ministers
took advantage of it to turn their
country into its bridge for the supply
of diesel to Ukraine especially at the
beginning of the conflict diesel that
would be used above all to supply
military vehicles they did so precisely
in response to a specific request from
the Ukrainian government to the
Bulgarian authorities but the question
that many of you may be asking is if the
refinery in Bulgaria is loaned by Lukoil
which is a big Russian Oil Company how
could they get the Russians to export
diesel to a country they had just gone
to war against
it seems that in order to achieve this a
great operation of deception was
orchestrated many of the workers at Luke
oil's own refinery in Bulgaria being
against the war agreed to comply with
the Bulgarian government's requests
specifically Bulgaria needs
approximately 50 of the diesel
production of this Refinery for its
domestic consumption the Surplus was
almost exclusively sent to Ukraine we
are talking about volumes exported to
Ukraine between January and November of
2022 totaling around 700 million euros
in fuel 1 000 times more than in 2021.
this was done with virtually no one
knowing about it and paradoxically it
was done with Russian oil that's what I
said with Russian oil the diesel that
was entering Ukraine through Bulgaria
came from imported oil from Russia
refined by Luke oil and then shipped to
the neighboring country through Romania
and trains and tanker trucks to supply
the Ukrainian War Machine in total
Bulgaria has covered up to 40 of all the
diesel needed by Ukraine and the
surprising method that's to say without
this ruse zelenski's government would
have had many problems in resisting the
Russian Onslaught at the beginning of
the war
foreign
but that's not all perhaps the most
interesting part of petcov's little lie
is that Bulgaria is not sending weapons
but we now know that this was not
entirely true either it's come to light
that at the beginning of the invasion
Bulgaria delivered to Ukraine numerous
rounds of ammunition for its artillery
let's just say that they took advantage
of the fact that the Bulgarian Army is
mostly equipped with Soviet equipment
specifically the petcov government
maneuvered to deliver to Ukraine large
quantities of ammunition for Ukrainian
Grand multiple rocket launchers through
third-party companies based in countries
such as Poland or the Czech Republic
there are those who will not consider
this to be weaponless but the fact is
that no matter how we look at it
delivering ammunition means delivering
ornaments so yes Petrov also lied about
this and he did it to help Ukraine
what is less clear is the extent to
which he actually managed to do it in
secret as in April 2022 we find out this
piece of news Russia's gas prom suspends
supplies to Poland and Bulgaria
coincidence no idea we can't know if the
reaction to Russia's gas prom is related
to Bulgarian Aid to Ukraine but at the
very least it's pretty striking in any
case the amaze thing about this whole
story is how the Bulgarian government or
at least part of the government
maneuvered to help Ukraine on this line
to deliver tons of ammunition and
Russian oil to the ukrainians so of
course the question now is besides the
fear of running out of energy supplies
what other motive could petcov have for
acting so secretly at that time doesn't
it sound strange that a NATO country
would have to maneuver practically in
secret when many others were loudly
voicing their support and sending in the
big guns well let's take a look
thank you
a country caught in disaster
as we've already told you at the
beginning of this video the political
situation in Bulgaria is not in its
finest Hour deadlocked governments
elections every few months ineffective
government coalitions things in Sofia
are so tense that any false step could
anger some government partners and could
end up with a cabinet exploding and new
elections being called again an example
of all this is precisely the government
of petkov which barely lasted little
more than half a year from December 2021
to August 2022. however contrary to what
many of you will surely be Imagining the
end of this government did not really
have to do with the Ukraine issue but
came about because of disagreements over
budgets and Bulgaria's position on North
macedonia's Ascension to the European
Union we've already said earlier that in
this country if it is not one thing it's
going to be the other one the thing is
at the time of making this video
Bulgaria's prime minister galab donov
foreign
a gentleman who was a minister in two
previous governments who ran as an
independent and will be passing through
until the next elections in April 2023
but let's not get sidetracked getting
back to the subject of petrov's secrecy
and lies there are a couple things we
need to keep in mind the first thing is
that pedcov headed a difficult
government composed of social liberal
centrists cruel Western conservatives
and a left-wing Coalition led by the
Bulgarian Socialist Party for those of
you who know nothing about Bulgarian
politics which I imagine is the vast
majority the Bulgarian Socialist Party
is the direct descendant of the
Bulgarian Communist party and in recent
years it has been moving towards
increasingly russophile and socially
conservative possessions do you want an
example we'll take a look at this the
Bulgarian Socialist Party is against the
extension of the sanctions against
Russia because they hurt the Bulgarian
national interest the Bulgarian economy
agriculture tourism Cornelia ninova
leader of the Bulgarian Socialist Party
in short if all the countries that had
something to lose from the sanctions had
thought only of themselves no agreement
would have been reached and Putin would
have been perfectly happy the fact is
that having this party with four
ministers in the government was not the
best scenario for getting tough on
Russia or or in fact to lead to anything
at all but of course the opinion on the
streets did not exactly help much either
[Music]
in general the Bulgarian political class
or at least those large parties which
options to govern tend to be pro-western
as are the country's economic Elites if
only because of the steady stream of
millions of Euros that are pouring into
Bulgaria thanks to European Union funds
funds that have become a tremendous
Lifeline for local tycoons
[Music]
however at a street level the situation
is somewhat different a large proportion
of the population frequently consumes
Russian propaganda and some media
Outlets are directly controlled by
Moscow which means that Russia continues
to have great power of influence over
public opinion in fact according to
analysis and international organizations
of all kinds there is one country where
Russian propaganda agencies and the
kremlin's disinformation strategies are
at ease it is precisely Bulgaria
Russia's information War expands through
Eastern Europe in Bulgaria the Kremlin
paid journalists political analysts and
other influential citizens two thousand
Euros a month to post pro-russian
content online researchers also have
uncovered sophisticated networks of fake
accounts spots and trolls in an
escalating spread of disinformation and
propaganda in the country in past videos
we've already spoken about the rule of
information Warfare in the hybrid
Warfare tactics but Russia typically
employs in its international relations
the result as you can see on screen is
that by mid-june 2022 and with the
Russian invasion already well underway
and a host of war crimes perfectly
documented barely half of the bulgarians
polled blamed Russia for the invasion of
Ukraine worse still more than one in
four believe that the West Was to blame
for what was happening by provoking
Russia remember that we are talking
about a country that is a member of both
NATO and the European Union evidently it
is likely that all this shifted with the
passage of time and Russian atrocities
but the problem is there and it helps to
understand why this country walks a
tightrope between the west and Russia in
fact the current Bulgarian government
has been doing strange things that many
of you may find hard to understand
things like this Bulgaria will allow a
Black Sea Refinery owned by a Russian
oil company to keep operating and
exporting oil products to the European
Union until the end of 2024 despite
warnings by Brussels that it is against
the block sanctions the deal between
Bulgaria and russian-owned Luke oil will
give an additional 350 million euro
dollar boost to Boca areas budget
according to estimates by the government
in Sofia in other words it seems that
Bulgaria wants to take advantage of its
particular exemption on Russian oil
sanctions to do business and bring
Russian oil into the European Union
whatever the case at this point the
questions are over to you what do you
think about former prime minister pitkov
secretly helping Ukraine are countries
like Bulgaria and Hungary reliable NATO
allies leave us your comments and
opinions below and now if you found this
video interesting don't forget to like
And subscribe to all of us here at
visualpolitics so you don't miss any of
our upcoming ones all the best and I'll
see you next time
[Music]
foreign